.
>> Pete: YOU DESERVE TO SLEEP IN
TOMORROW.
GREAT COVERAGE.
IT'S BEEN THREE DAYS SINCE POLLS
CLOSED AND WE STILL DON'T KNOW
WHO WILL CONTROL THE HOUSE AND
THE SENATE.
WE'RE NOT EVEN CLOSE TO KNOWING.
IN NEVADA, POLL WORKERS ARE
SLOWLY COUNTING THE VOTES.
STILL AT LEAST 50,000 LEFT TO
COUNT.
ARIZONA HAS HUNDREDS OF
THOUSANDS OF VOTES LEFT TO
COUNT.
WE WON'T KNOW THE RESULT UNTIL
NEXT WEEK, IF WE'RE LUCKY.
THIS ISN'T HOW IT USED TO BE.
IT USED TO TAKE A FEW HOURS TO
FIND OUT WHO WON THE RACE.
WHEN YOU WERE WAITING UNTIL 3:00
A.M. THAT FELT LATE.
NOW IT TAKES A WEEK OR MORE.
IF REPUBLICANS WANT TO CHANGE
THIS NEW NORMAL, THEY HAVE TO
WIN STATE ELECTIONS.
BUT HOW ARE THEY GOING TO DO
THAT EXACTLY?
MANY DEMOCRATS NOW VOTE WITH
THEIR FEET.
THEY MOVE TO RED STATES BECAUSE
THEIR BLUE STATES WERE RUINED BY
LEFT WING POLICIES.
LESS POLICE, MORE CRIME AND
HIGHER TAXES.
I DON'T BLAME THEM FROM MOVING
FROM CALIFORNIA TO NEVADA AND
ARIZONA HERE'S THE PROBLEM AND
YOU KNOW IT.
THEY BRING THEIR PROBLEMS WITH
THEM.
THEY VOTE FOR PEOPLE WITH THE
STAPLE PROGRESSIVE IDEAS THAT
MADE THEM LEAVE IN THE FIRST
PLACE.
IT DOESN'T MAKE ANY SENSE BUT
THAT'S WHAT'S HAPPENING.
VOTERS REPUBLICANS ARE SHIPPING
BUS LOADS BORDER FAILURE.
TEXAS GOVERNOR GREG ABBOTT
CELEBRATED HIS 300TH BUST.
I FULLY SUPPORT, BUT WHAT
HAPPENED.
IDENTIFICATION.
DO YOU THINK THEY CARE IF THEY
ARE CITIZENS?
YOU KNOW THE ANSWER.
HUGE VOTE TOTALS IN BLUE CITIES
CITIESIS HOW DEMOCRATS WIN.
LOOK AT ANY MAP.
THE ENTIRE STATE IS RED.
EXCEPT FOR A FEW BLUE DOTS.
THAT'S ALL THEY NEED.
ELECTIONS TAKE LONGER AND
BELONGER AND SKEW MORE AND MORE
BLUE.
IF YOU SPEAK UP AGAINST IT AN
ELECTION DENIER.
WORST TITLE COULD THEY POSSIBLY
PUT ON YOU?
BUT WHAT'S A BIGGER THREAT TO
DEMOCRACY THAN DRAWING OUT
ELECTIONS?
ERODING TRUST IN THOSE VERY
ELECTIONS WHETHER THERE IS FRAUD
OR NOT DEPUTING THE BLUE CITY
FIASCO IS THE REAL THREAT.
THEY SAY PEOPLE DON'T NEED AN
I.D. TO VOTE.
I USE AN IDENTIFICATION TO VOTE
ON TUESDAY.
MANY OF YOU DO.
IT'S NOT HARD.
SAYING BLACK OR BROWN OR POOR
PEOPLE CAN'T GET IDS IS BEYOND
RACIST.
THE SOFT BIGOTRY OF NO
IDENTIFICATION.
NONE OF THIS MAKES ANY SENSE
UNLESS THEY WANT IT TO WORK THIS
WAY.
WHAT DOES AMERICA LOOK LIKE IF
WE KEEP GOING IN THIS DIRECTION?
WHEN WE WERE YOUNG, YOU AND I,
OUR ENTIRE FAMILIES USED TO COME
OUT AND SEE THE TOWN'S PARADES.
FOURTH OF JULY, THANKSGIVING,
MEMORIAL DAY, IT WAS A BIG DEAL.
CELEBRATING AMERICA WAS
IMPORTANT FROM COAST TO COAST.
I DON'T CARE IF YOU ARE IN A RED
STATE OR BLUE STATE, OUR
FAMILIES AND GRANDPARENTS DID
IT.
TODAY IS VETERANS DAY AFTER ALL.
AND MAY GOD BLESS OUR WARRIORS.
WE ARE GRATEFUL TO YOU TODAY AND
EVERY DAY AND ALL THE FAMILIES
SUPPORT THEM.
PITTSBURGH TODAY HELD ITS ANNUAL
VETERANS DAY PARADE.
BUT IT LOOKED A LITTLE DIFFERENT
THIS YEAR.
DO YOU SEE A CROWD THERE TO
SUPPORT THE PEOPLE WHO DEFENDED
THEIR FREEDOM?
NO.
A LITTLE RAIN SCARED THEM AWAY.
WE SUPPORT THE VETS, UNLESS IT
MEANS GETTING WET.
BUT AT LEAST PITTSBURGH HELD A
PARADE.
SOME PLACES IN AMERICA ARE STILL
THERE FOR THEIR VETERANS.
IN FACT, I WAS AT A VETERANS DAY
EVENT THIS MORNING IN READING,
PENNSYLVANIA.
IT WAS AN AMAZING CELEBRATION.
BUT THE EVENTUALLY WASN'T PUT ON
BY THE TOWN.
IT WAS THROWN BY CORPORATIONS IN
READING WHO SUPPORT THE CITY.
AND HAVE PURE GRATITUDE FOR THE
VETS WHO LIVE IN THAT COMMUNITY.
CIVIC RITUAL IS INCREDIBLY
IMPORTANT TO PERPETUATING
PATRIOTISM.
IT'S WHY I JOINED THE ARMY.
I CAN LITERALLY DRAW A STRAIGHT
LINE FROM THE PATRIOTIC PARADES
I ATTENDED AS A KID IN THE TINY
TOWN OF ONE AMINGO IN SOUTHERN
MINNESOTA TO THE REASON I RAISED
MY RIGHT HAND TO SERVE.
BUT THAT'S ALL SLOWLY DYING.
THE AMERICA YOU KNEW GROWING UP
IS ON LIFE SUPPORT.
KIDS TODAY DON'T SEE REVERENCE
FOR VETERANS.
THEY ARE NOT BEING TAUGHT THAT
INSTEAD IN OUR SCHOOLINGS WE
HAVE LGBTQ ABCD PLUS MONTH.
I HAVE LOST TRACK.
EARTH DAY, OF COURSE IS PUBLIC
SCHOOL'S HIGHEST OF HOLIDAYS.
AL GORE THE HIGH PRIEST DID YOUR
KIDS' SCHOOL EVEN HOLD A
VETERANS DAY EVENT TODAY?
PROBABLY NOT BE ENFORCED IN THE
SCHOOL.
WHY DO YOU THINK THERE IS SUCH A
HIGH TURNOUT OF YOUNG FIRST TIME
VOTERS FOR DEMOCRATS?
DEMOCRATS LIKE INCOHERENT
SOCIALIST TELLING YOU AMERICA IS
RACIST.
MEN CAN GET PREGNANT AND CLIMATE
CHANGE IS THE BIGGEST THREAT TO
THE WORLD EVER AMERICAN HATING
SOCIALIST WHO VOTE.
YOUNG PEOPLE CONDITIONED TO SEE
THE WORLD THROUGH THE HARD
LEFT'S EYES.
DON'T ASK ANY QUESTIONS.
IGNORE CRIME.
IGNORE THE BORDER.
IT'S YOUR FAULT.
LET THEM CROSS.
FREE SPEECH IS FOR EXTREMISTS.
DON'T PAY OFF YOUR LOANS, THAT'S
FOR CHURCHES.
DON'T LIKE A WORD?
JUST CHANGE THE MEANING JUST A
BIT, YOU KNOW, EQUALITY NOW
EQUITY, PARENTS CERTAINLY STAY
OUT OF THAT TRANSITION NOW IT
TAKES A FEW WEEKS TO COUNT ALL
THE BALLOTS THAT'S NORMAL
COUNTING CONTINUES AND HUNDREDS
OF THOUSANDS OF BALLOTS YET TO
GO.
OFFICIALS TELL US DESPITE WHAT
YOU MIGHT READ ON SOCIAL MEDIA
THAT IS NOT EVIDENCE OF
SUSPICIOUS ACTIVITY OR ANY
INCOMPETENCE, IT'S NORMAL.
>> Pete: IT'S NORMAL.
JUST THE WAY IT IS.
TWITTER AGREED SAYING IT'S
COMPLETELY NORMAL.
NOTHING TO SEE HERE.
IT TAKES TIME TO COUNT ALL THE
VOTES CLICK ON THAT BLACK BAR TO
FIND OUT MORE.
IT USED TO TAKE A COUPLE OF
HOURS ON ELECTION NIGHT.
THAT DOESN'T WORK ANYMORE.
2020 WASN'T A FLUKE.
IT HAPPENED AGAIN IN 2022 AND
RIGHT NOW IS SHAPING UP FOR
ROUND 3 IN 2024.
HOW DID WE GET HERE?
AND WHAT, IF ANYTHING, WILL
REPUBLICANS DO ABOUT IT?
POINTING OUT THE PROBLEM IS NOT
ENOUGH.
SIMPLE IDEAS OF WHAT COULD
HAPPEN.
START WITH VOTER I.D.
PROVE HOW ARE JUST LIKE WHEN YOU
CASH A CHECK OR GET ON AUTO
PLANE OR PICK UP A PRESCRIPTION.
IT'S SIMPLE AND IT WORKS.
HOW ABOUT WE REMOVE ALL THE
EMERGENCY MEASURES THAT THEY
STARTED DURING COVID.
THE EMERGENCY IS OVER JOE BIDEN
SAID HIMSELF EVEN IF HE IS MAYBE
EXTENDING IT WE LEARNED TODAY.
THE EMERGENCY MEASURES FOR
VOTING SHOULD BE OVER, TOO.
AND FOR GOOD MEASURE, HOW ABOUT
WE TAKE DEAD PEOPLE OFF THE THE
VOTER ROLLS.
HOW ABOUT ENOUGH OF THIS VOTING
FOR MONTHS NONSENSE.
I BET YOU LIKE THE IDEA OF
PEOPLE VOTING ON ELECTION DAY.
I DO TOO.
OR WE COULD MAKE VOTING ONE
WEEKEND PLUS ELECTION DAY.
CAN YOU VOTE ON SATURDAY,
SUNDAY, MONDAY, OR TUESDAY.
THAT'S IT.
AND THEN YOU COUNT THE VOTES AND
IT TAKES A NIGHT.
NOT A WEEK TO DETERMINE THE
WINNER.
WE SHOULDN'T BE GOING INTO THE
WEEKEND AFTER ELECTION DAY WITH
THIS MANY QUESTIONS.
HOW MANY BALLOTS ARE LEFT TO
COUNT IN ARIZONA AND NED?
AND COUNTLESS OTHER HOUSE RACES
REQUEST ARE THEY BEING COUNTED.
DEMOCRATS CERTAINLY DON'T STEAM
CARE.
BUT WE DO.
I KNOW YOU DO IF WE DON'T WE MAY
NEVER SEE ANOTHER NORMAL OR
TRUSTED ELECTION DAY AHEAD KIDS
NEVER REALIZE NEW NORMAL IS YET